welcome to this video playing Mullen and
this is croatia i learnt the flex now I
really confuse them all the time okay
and we get the green fault hmm can I do
something else against the growing fault
let's try a funky line 9 a-4 maybe I can
confuse him a little bit how does why
play here 95 no I think he just keeps
that protected from a teammate of mine
used to play this night a for business
against the Guru felt okay so you're
taking is probably not a really good
idea rookie one maybe maybe just 51
getting the rook out of the diagonal
yeah I was thinking about that not not
sure if this if this is any good yeah if
i take it takes on be to you this does
not help maybe just a simple moves like
that threatens dtc five takes Bishop
takes Bishop takes Queen takes form for
a minimum minimum advantage very very
minimum okay but sometimes getting a
very dry position against a group of
player is not a bad thing I can also
take with the night no but I can let's
let's do this it's simple and not bad
aha so it's not taking on d4 he allows
me to take giving him a slight weakness
in the pawn structure however is some
activity to compensate for that for that
that's clear okay so a three
oh it's nice playing really actively
didn't see that coming but it's a good
move probably probably maybe not maybe
not if I get in Bishop c2 it's not clear
where the rookies actually heading let's
say rook the aid yet Bishop c2 should be
good for white I believe it's a
basically a double attack and now I have
them I have this improvement of my king
position the rook does not have many
squares if it goes to see for okay it
didn't then i would have had before I
guess okay what's happening here I
wonder maybe Bishop g4 is a move
should I maybe yeah okay let's let's
prevent that it's that's fairly slow i
know but i felt i should prevent Bishop
g4 let's see I want I really want on to
be on the D file oh it's tough to get
and bee farm yeah maybe this and then
rub q1
yeah it's probably really just equal
don't I really don't have any anything
great iam
maybe I can go 92 and F form things like
that gaining some space yum F 494 but I
have rope t7 at the end so this is not
that great
check thought at least
this looks nice maybe it's nothing but
Jim he probably really tests not want to
play rookies have now this is not a good
idea
yeah pressing water out of stone
no black was certainly equal but still
needs a needed some accuracy yeah I
thought about that but I think I can
really take p7 I have Bishop e3 check
it's important I like like Bishop
everyone happy should be three check
yeah just bishop or not let me think
about it Bishop d3 yeah I think it's
good i'm still attacking be 6 cm so he
has no one no active idea
Bishop see age
you know Jessica Luca piayed so i can
kinda trance the ponds
maybe Bishop g5 was a move my look it
looks fairly fairly fairly go down and
ponds going to a six kinky for first no
way six check time morning
King be six then a seven this is one way
to do it the only thing to be cautious
with us that possibly have the wrong
check the wrong upon but this is sure to
seal the deal black five hits on time I
get the Jeep on yeah it was a very dry
position around here like you should
really be okay he is active enough for
sure rook a formed yeah I think maybe
Bishop g4 was better here intending to
take on f3 and then go to d4 I have a
weakness on d4 that's very very
important after Bishop g4 I maybe you
need to play 91 and then F 392 I think
this this helped me a lot to a
coordinator and here maybe I'm enjoying
a slight slight advantage the compass
0.6 m already intending f4 but he ran
right into that and after this he's
definitely in trouble Group C 5 was
possible I didn't think of that in the
game but it makes lots of sense of
course like this
that's very nice chap TM widest in
excellent shape just just has a hard
time to to keep this to keep this and
then I think I did a reasonable job from
a technical point of view and always
keeping keeping the win okay thanks for
watching